[Musique]
on prend la session de mes participez
pas trop comment la Coupe du Monde
Qatar parce que simplement c'est à vous
suivre contre la société contre
l'humanité c'est c'est l'obscénité de
capitalisme des grands chantiers à la
base de 6000 personnes migrantes qui
sont mortes nous comment traduire en
France nous ne pouvons pas valider ça
probablement
mais l'argent ne soit problème c'est un
problème des valeurs c'est un problème
de justice c'est un problème de
l'empathie
j'adore justement regarder la Coupe du
monde mais là c'est un peu c'est ça qui
me rend un peu triste c'est que bah
à cause des conditions de cette Coupe du
monde
je me dis que c'est bien de faire de
faire cet acte de ne pas la regarder
justement je fais le plus grand fan de
football mais en tout cas je trouve ça
je trouve ça bien de boycotter d'abord
parce que
il y a les droits humains qui sont pas
respectés
c'est un pays qui a tué beaucoup de
beaucoup de personnes pour construire
les stages là-bas donc moi forcément je
suis contre